go happy
birthday to
you happy
birthday to you that's what I heard at
6:30 a.m. this morning don't lie it was
like 6:10 we know this guy's like 6:00
a.m. cuz this Cy guy came in my room and
wish me a happy
birthday and
honestly um last week my bro was asking
me like what do you want to do for your
birthday you do anything crazy and I was
like you know what you know what makes
me really really happy just being able
to have my birthday and spend time with
my favorite people in the world which is
my Cy wife and my Cy son and just eating
yummy food is going to make my heart
feel so good so the first thing we're
going to do is going to get some yummy
Mexican breakfast and there's this place
called Kasa L desuno did I pronounce it
right yep what does that mean uh
Breakfast House oh that's what it means
theya is breakfast yeah so um I have a
whole list of Vegas places I want to eat
and i' I've been wanting to come here
this place has the mazapan is it called
mazapan masaan mazapan the uh what that
Z sa Z maaan and then it has that Rose
like peanut thing pancakes yeah well
that's masaan you just described masaan
yep so we have masaan pancakes do you
like thatp shin do you like that do you
like that oh yeah he loves it you know
that Mexican candy that has peanuts in
it and grandma gives it to you and
there's a rose on top she leaves it in
the freezer and it tastes like peanuts
oh yeah I think so they have P they have
pancakes like that here was that crazy
BS yeah so we're going to get that for
breakfast when we get back you got to
show them what we got you okay fine all
right so while I was driving M was
looking at the Yelp to get a head start
so that she could see the pictures and
know what to order and the whole time I
just keep hearing the sounds of approval
tell me what you saw and how you feel
about this place so I'm very particular
about my Mexican food I mean I feel like
you would relate to it like everyone can
relate to it if you grew up in a house
where your parents or a parent knew how
to cook pretty well you're kind of
holding that to the standard like that's
your standard so my mom cooks really
really well my grandma cooks really
really well um um so now anytime I get
Mexican food it's always subpar I'm
always like H like just even the rice
you know the orange rice Mexican rice
even that I'm like you can't even nail
this I have yet to eat anything better
than your mom's cooking in Mex Mexican
Cuisine so this restaurant though it has
all the right either garnishes or
ingredients on it like I'll see and and
it could also be you know the way my mom
made it is not the right way or the
authentic way but anytime I see anyone
nail it that way so a specific example
would be like chilak kilas I didn't grow
up with having chilakil uh having um
scrambled eggs on top top of my chilas
like that to me is so odd um so this
place doesn't do it like that and they
use CA cheese um that's like the legit
cheese well I mean it just depends on
the style but my mom uses CA because it
like has a extra dankness yeah like it's
salty so it adds the saltness factor to
it and they use queso fresco like the
like the drizzle dot on it yeah and I'm
like God damn they use the right type of
either they make their own tortilla
chips or just tortilla chips to use the
correct ones and I'm like brother the
the beans I'm particular about beans too
they look legit as heck and they have a
g gansito pancake and gansitos so
gansitos is like the Mexican version I
guess of like um of uh Twinkie oh oh
like a um it's like it's like like a
supermarket dessert snack yes yeah like
a twinky but like our Twinkies are way
more advanced cuz it it's like chocolate
on like a hard crunchy chocolate on the
out outside it's obviously the the bread
on the inside but then it has like a
layer of like strawberry jam like damn
everyone's washing cars out here like
they're about this is like the fourth
one there's another guy right here that
also lets you know that this place is
legit they're hust cuz this is straight
up like in the hood yeah there's no part
oh maybe here yeah this place is in the
hood and you could just tell everyone's
hustling in the morning I love that East
Del East Del East Vegas East whatever
are we East type of M no we're in North
Vegas I think these guys about to leave
but I'm excited and it's next to a
beauty salon you know it's legit yeah
here is another sign if a place is legit
or not I don't even think they have a
legit storefront I think you're just
going through the
back anytime where like things they just
freestyle the business you know it's
good cuz they're paying attention to the
right things products and they don't
know proper business operations or
anything you know they focus on the food
that's all it is so we're coming coming
through the
backa let me see if there is an actual
front I'm sure there is oh you got to go
all the way
around well the way they mapped us is to
come in through the back oh look here's
just some of the pictures oh my God look
at
that dude all the food looks
insane I don't know what to get like
here for it the Chila kilas look good
the wett look good yeah that looks like
my mom Style looks good that looks good
my mom likes to cook the Y this looks
good all of this looks like my mom's
cooking oh man we got to bring her mom
here she doesn't want my mom doesn't
like one the places where she can make
the food so she doesn't want to make the
food ever mom put the knife in my nose
would you put the knife in your nose for
wait is that chocolate or a scab on his
lip a scab oh so you know when you like
your your your um lip gets raw so we
know not to wet it you want to keep it
dry so it dries off he at the opposite
he kept wetting it and then trying to
rub it off oh I see look at these
pancakes dude this the masaan right
there yeah this one that's the one with
the rose one Papa's going to order that
that let me show you what Masa you know
what it is he loves Masa panis but we
just haven't sh TAA loves Masa panis but
only at Grandma's house this one I I
know oh show show
Papa yep no don't be like that this one
Amazon I don't know that's what it
linked me to yep that's it right there I
hated this growing
I love so good the flavor is good but I
was just like this is for old people but
now well they have it on pancakes guess
what bean boom dude I'm going to try the
gito ones get it get everything it's
your
birthday it's your birthday it feels
like it's my birthday it's your birthday
it's your
birthday all right look at this food wos
sanos
oh got maaan pancakes oh show with eggs
oh look at that look at this whipped
cream it's like picturesque and then now
see the Moment of Truth like your
childhood
M [__] yeah yeah oh yeah this is so good
my mouth put some on my mouth you bad
girl you want in your mouth bad boy yeah
in your
mouth
m
just tastes like the home I never
had so I don't know if this is authentic
or not but I feel like the best way to
judge any Mexican breakfast place you
have to get the Chiles or the w sanos we
got
both am I supposed to eat this with my
hand or it doesn't matter up to you I'm
eat like this oh the cheese on the side
I've never seen anybody eat it like that
before m is it like my mom's it's really
good I need a little bit
salt the flavor is really good yeah
that's fair it looks like all the
flavors are on
point
guys enjoy it does feel like like
someone made it in their home kitchen
yeah
M so I usually hate doing this I like
eating all my sweets after when the
Savory is done but when you wait then
it's not in its best form anymore so I
have to just take a little sneak peek
you know what I'm saying I have to oh
there's all this like cream stuff on it
look at
that
oh
oh what does it taste
like a really light and fluffy pancake
with maaan on
it it's not
heavy I eat this whole thing
I not in the way where it's like like
you bought it at supermarket you know
like Supermarket cheesecake feels
different than like a
light yeah it doesn't feel heavy at all
I got to try it I don't like feel like
Asian Bakery style you ASI yeah I don't
like mixing my flavors either but you
sold it man let me get some of that
masaan get some of that the
cream M right it's like light you eat
the whole thing this is really masaan
pancakes yeah it really tastes like
masaan this my new favorite Mexican spot
happy birthday bab thank you so
breakfast was a success and uh that was
something that Papa wanted one thing
that I had suggested for his birthday I
was like okay well what do you want to
do um he goes I don't know I kind of
just want to stay home like all I've
been doing is just traveling back and
forth so much that I just really want to
spend some time home and I'm like
what if we pull out the extra mattress
cuz we have an extra mattress for
anytime we have like guests come over
with little kids or we just don't have
enough space it's always good to have a
mattress right like what if we get out
the extra mattress and then we lay it
out we move the coffee table from our
living room and we lay it on the floor
and
Papa was all for it look at this guy
look how comfy this looks Mama guys we
have some snack and we get home this we
have a we have must watch TV and we have
lot to some water what are we watching
comeone of course and look what I even
did to the TV yeah you tilted it I see
this the perfect oh my God Beauty angle
you see this yeah you want me to bring
down the shades oh yeah and guys look at
that it's a daytime SL W it's a daytime
slumber party that's cute okay I'm ready
to jump in jump in Mama all right back
on the road for lunch and guess what I'm
getting for lunch
I think it's kind of uh not coincidental
or ironic but what's the word ironic
what are you trying to say it's like um
it didn't happen this way on purpose
Havey accident but but we're we're
ending up getting the culture the
cuisine of our cultures so we got cuz we
got Mexican breakfast coincidence and
then now we're going to get Taiwanese
food yeah it's a coincidence so I was
like oh that's C that's exactly what I
wanted to eat today is coincidence it
was
coincidental that we're going to go and
I found a spot dude I love all these
food vloggers cuz like they find all
these gems and they they tell you all
the good stuff to eat cuz one of them
they're in the cut yeah this one is
especially in the cut they even said on
the reels like hey they don't have
social media so this one it's like hard
to find um but this is the address go
there they don't know anything about any
of that stuff but the food's really good
and I'm like dude I love places like
that I want want to support places that
feel super mom and pop and this one's
called Taiwan Deli so they just kept it
straightforward so I'm going to check it
you I don't think you mean mom and pop I
think you want to support places that
are passionate about the whatever
they're putting out there and Mom and
Pop too oh cuz you know a lot of these
like M and pot places they they don't
have a sophisticated Marketing System
you know they don't like oh yeah you
checking on Y and you get 10% off your
first me they don't know any of that
stuff they just go I just want to make
food I don't want people to eat my food
what language is that I don't know oh
okay but yeah that's what they do you
know what I'm
saying see that I yawned without opening
my mouth go no I I can't do it again I
just yawned
oh so M bear and taer are already inside
and I love everything that I'm seeing
about this place I love the simple very
traditional looking outside it's just
straight up Taiwan Deli I like that I
saw the owner come out and escort a
bunch of Mandarin speakers out cuz I
feel like when you have like Taiwanese
people going to a Taiwanese joint it's
actually made for Taiwanese people and
it's going to have that like back home
feel you know and I looked at the menu
and unfortunately I came with a really
small crew so we can't actually order a
ton of food cuz it's just me m be and
taica but I would love to come with more
friends so we can order like 10 dishes
cuz there's a bunch of things so
unfortunately I won't be able to do this
place justice but the part that I am the
most happy about is this old fashioned
meat sauce with noodle and egg it's
called ta Ro because um even in La maybe
only like two out of like 10 um toe
spots would have it and it's a very like
simple like home-cooked type dish and I
don't know why a lot of places don't
have it but that's actually my favorite
dish so the fact that they have this
makes me very happy I'm like ooh cuz
even like remember all the places I try
to take you to M bear I'm like I wish
they have I wish they have it but they
don't so I resort to like baked pork
chop or res pork chop rice or fried
chicken with rice but they have that and
they also have stinky tofu so I can't
wait to share that with you on my
birthday all
right hey monkey man do you want to
smell the stinkiest food in the
world what is that so this is
traditional Taiwanese dish called stinky
tofu if you bite it I'll give you 10
bucks that was I was supposed to smell
it you could just smell
it saw your face does it smell like what
you smell no I know what it smells like
Mama smelled it many times what does it
smell like I don't know smell
good you look like the Grinch you know
the Grinch is
face you want a bite if you bite if you
take one bite and you swallow it I'll
give you 10 bucks to yeah you want to
okay let me see if it's hot they have 30
bucks yeah you've been saving lots of
money I think said if I have 20 20 30
bucks I might get like a machine gun or
something
look at the little trip
MK dude that's 10 bucks I can't believe
you did it I'm really proud of you
actually you're brave how's it taste
like does it taste weird or I just taste
like nothing yeah it doesn't taste
stinky cuz even to me it's kind of
stinky
I change I think change oh that one
looks like a 10 with an extra zero tell
them
PE Papa I I'll I'll VMO
you okay so I got so excited I just
started eating I just realized I didn't
introduce anything so here's the
introduction this is the noodles that I
grew up on it's called the minc meat
with noodle that I'm really happy to
have cuz almost no place has it gotp
stickers which is like a fried dumpling
I got it with leaks so it's a different
flavor from this one this was napa
cabbage then we got um like signature
style tanese fried chicken with has like
the fried basil and yes you can eat the
leaves and we got the stinky tofu as TAA
just ate showed you guys green onion
pancake May bear got the soup and tac's
been eating a little bit of everything
getting in touch with this culture
especially stinky
tofu all morning too you got in touch
with this culture yeah you got both
sides play play WoW play
play why are you brushing your teeth I
tell you I was going to ask
I was thinking about before you came in
here what I was like can we drink and
have sex tonight what the [__] why are
you brushing your teeth no you liar I
was I was thinking about can you
please I like outfit hurry I had [__] I
ate [__] nugget and what's [__] nuggets
what's that dish called stick it
over okay so now it's the cake time Papa
didn't want a full cake cuz there's
three of us and he also wants to watch
his figure he doesn't want to go
overboard like he always does normally
does I don't want to go back I've been
doing really good I want
to so we went to 85° and we all were
given permission to pick a slice of cake
so Tao which one did you get the one of
the the biggest one the biggest one red
velvet Papa got a cheesecake which I'm
very surprised that you got by the way
it's a little I I was looking for
something kind of decadent and thicker
you get like a chocolate mousse or
something see thicker I don't want
something fluffy and mousse is light so
I wanted something like
and then I got a little strawberry one
and we all get a candle which ta is
going to light go for it
dude whoa is that the F1 race
car oh is it running out of batteries
seriously oh did we charge it since last
time I don't think so cuz it R on the
batteries last time how dare
[Music]
you we ran out of
batteries no problem we got this okay
you just pess it down okay okay it's
kind of hard okay it's kind of not for
kids that's why don't too scared I'm
really scared no all the way down scared
of
what I can't I can't do it it's not
going to
[Applause]
explode kids and fire they love it they
love it runs in the quad what about this
one hey what about
[Music]
you
ready happy birthday
to
you happy
birthday to you CH cha CH happy
birthday dear
papa cha cha CH happy
birthday to you hey guys before we vog
what if we and papa blows out his cake
and I blow up my cake and you blow yours
cake no papa needs to do it he's in the
he's going to make a wish okay make a
wish Papa make a wish make a wish make a
wish tell us what it is what's the wish
that's it no no no no you're not
supposed to
do
w
w he's a crazy guy guys don't worry is
that
hot
look he's got his glass of milk ready
and everything you this is not Amateur
hour this man knows what he's doing
Water by accident let me tell you that
much yeah yeah you know what
good okay enjoy Papa thank you all right
so I feel like I'm as red as a cranberry
actually I don't look that bad I thought
it was way redder but anyways we spent
the rest of my birthday in the hot tub
drinking some beers very Cy not beers
Just One Beer there's two beers you one
for you one for me okay so great that
that was CI a little bonding time with
me and
Mama and I had a wonderful birthday
thank you Mama for giving me the best
birthday ever you're welcome thank you
for giving me your best birthday ever
cuz I was trying to plan like a going
out and you're were like I just want to
stay home and watch movies and I was
like m birthday yeah cuz I'm so freaking
busy like all the time that it's just
nice to be just still like I feel like I
don't even get to enjoy the house cuz
I'm barely in it I really got to enjoy
it today it made me feel so good so I'll
see you guys tomorrow